Dianne Feinstein has been hospitalized
she is the Democrat Senator she's quite
aged she's a woman of a certain age she
is 90 I think now she had shingles
earlier this year all sorts of health
problems that came from that she's in a
wheelchair she seems to have some
cognitive issues she had a fall she was
briefly hospitalized she then returned
home and people are calling on her to
step down I see why Democrats want her
to step down they want her to step down
because there's a Democrat Governor in
California and he can appoint some very
young robust far leftist Senator to
replace Dianne Feinstein who by the
standards of the democratic party is
relatively moderate today I get why they
want her to why do we want her to
because she's old she we don't need all
these old people anymore come on it's
embarrassing how old she is let's go get
her out of here
that's it that's the that is that is the
degree of strategic and tactical
sophistication on the right I'm sorry to
say for a lot of the establishment
Republicans what good is done by
replacing her right now nothing what bad
is done you get a younger more energetic
more radical Senator who's doing more
stuff